Carol
I'd hope she wouldn't have to witness
this where's Siri nearby listen shut up
I've heard enough of your [ __ ] draw
your weapon let's get this over with
think I'm gonna fall for that no chance
you're wrong trusted you once won't make
that mistake again I am NOT your foe I
am merely helping sorella I don't
believe you can't not after all that's
happened will you believe me avelox
speaks the truth I asked him to help me
open it down because I aim to enter it
why the hell would you do this the wild
hunts been defeated
the white frost has not
the prophecies are true i have seen
world's bound in ice I know what awaits
you only the elder blood can stop the
white frost only I can stop it
you don't have to make this sacrifice
you're wrong the white frost is
inevitable it will come to freeze the
world one after the other eradicated all
life
only I can stop the destruction I've
given it much thought and made my
decision
there's got to be another way what can
you know about saving the world silly
you're put a winter
this is my story not yours we mustn't
let me finish telling him
I'm sorry
you
the gentleman will follow
clean to me a day to report the novigrad
delegation is half day's travel from
here they truly are rush whatever
outside hitter fought off it will he get
his will and rest or be sent straight to
download at his age the German ha big
labor costs his Imperial Majesty evades
net hand as quick
you
enough
speak Syria is dead
how did it happen the white cold
they're familiar with the prophecy Siri
tried to stop it she did but paid the
ultimate price word is the body and
doubt it will ever be found who else
knows ha Alvin sage but I doubt you'll
find him either I'm Jana foot she's
decided to stay in the north provided
you don't object I don't unto you
you
plenty of work for witches after a war
I'll travel east maybe North did Sevilla
say did she ask you to convey anything
you
you
we didn't talk about you I see
if there's nothing else that is what you
may go
which are I do not wish to see you ever
again
need help with your wagon
thing will be all right hi you betcha
we'll manage true the barrels are ample
we shall pour some off of each soon
change is coming true no denying it milf
guard freeze yet here it seemed nothing
could move them let their wine behind
too that's generous sure you don't need
any help I believe we will manage where
you had it and harris den by the looks
of it yeah supposed to meet someone
first the former camp side of enough
guardians you take care now
move it
come on
Master oars
probably got held back
you
you're late soldiers blocking the roads
I know no matter you have it as agreed
38 and a half inch blade wait just under
40 ounces silver plated Siddha right
steel core glyphs and runes both the
length of the blade and on the hilt
beautiful it in a trade for three
decades only the best swordsman of the
coin for my layers when I say no which
it has or ever had a better weapon
you're to trust me reputation precedes
you master would I'd never doubt you the
inscription as you asked
Syria
swallow classic elder speech rooms no
styling simple and precise may I it is
yours if you'd like to test it at my
Luckies / a training dummy mm-hmm your
payment gems only has requested if
you've an eye out for work heard a
Striga sproul in the Mario forest Thanks
need to visit the tavern first but after
who knows good luck in the path nature
let's go
sure to take all your rubbish with you
yeah you will talk come on now clueless
yes if I me you've done half what you
promised I'll come back and take you to
nilfgaard you were to stay here
and protect her the noble Lord tagboard
assumes his lands to rule with grace and
Justice Holmes burdens and encumbrances
or to any other nearby four-way stay
here forever for us the black ones wish
I stole it to you no longer
is it done yes did he believe you I have
no idea for the cockatrice and we've a
new contract it won't pay much but I
think it worth the toilet you've been
busy it's yours
you
which is sort swallow hmm beautiful may
I not here you'll have ample opportunity
soon enough Witcher let's try it out
then
the invader from the South achieved
complete picture from the vrat of its
tactical Dinah's the northern realms
could not withstand amir's council
sneakers black banners appeared over
novigrad and all the day weary of rebel
raids a mere VAR Emrys conceded
restoring tameria has a realm in beach
to the empire when the guerrillas laid
down their arms the Emperor shifted his
forces to other fronts ooh milk guards
victory Marian's got their country back
history once again through the
consummate Christie having dealt with
route of it here about Emrys did the
same with enemies domestic the Emperor's
loyal spies named aldred conspired
against him traders soldiers and
aristocrats alike though their mutiny
had only been a murky plan the Emperor
showed no mercy as was his wont while
the continent bled engulfed by war
Skellig abloom dunder ceressus
enlightened rule unlike those who had
come before her the young Queen did not
raid foreign shores looking and said to
her people tending to her now
domination prosper though its fangs of
your were done cyrilla Nona Ellen
Rhiannon aired to milk dogs from shows
the life of a Witcher Gerald taught her
all he knew every skill he possessed
then each set off on your own soon word
of the ashen haired rich heiress had
spread throughout the Lord from the
Yoruba mountains of cookies while
monarch smooth borders and populations
geraldton yennefer lived a calm quiet
life far from all things political they
breakfasted well afternoon or often than
not in bed and passed the days on lazy
strolls and long conversations boring
you say perhaps but both had sought this
more than anything else